charred remains of what some of the
children were wearing when a u.s drone
hit their house
some of them were inside others playing
outside near a parked car
among the 10 people killed in kabul on
august 29 were two-year-old sumaya and
ayat along with three-year-old malika
seven-year-old arwen was playing near
the car
twenty-year-old zamir six-year-old
binyamin and eleven-year-old farzad were
inside
sixteen-year-old faisal was learning to
reverse the car with his father zamirai
nasir was preparing for prayers
neighbors rushed with buckets to put out
the fire they were too late
my daughter
for the family which lost everything the
u.s admission of killing civilians
brings no closure
amel wants compensation and is demanding
the u.s government relocate his family
from afghanistan
at first they should investigate after
that they should target it we are
anointing people we are don't do any
mistake right now i heard that america
accept their mistake
uh yeah my
lasting member of my family that i wanna
adjust ties for usa for hazard
organization and all over the world
before the acknowledgment of the u.s
stone strike which killed civilians
taliban leader anasakani told al jazeera
that u.s drones targeted innocent people
in kabul haqqani says isil k controls no
base in afghanistan and it cannot be
used as a pretext to strike against the
afghan people and he says it's in breach
of the agreement signed with the u.s
last year in doha
violating the agreement is like inviting
war this doesn't help with peace and
prosperity it is misusing peace in a
wrong way now peace has come to this
country so if they continue to behave
like this the world should understand
that they want war not peace
the uk-based bureau of investigative
journalism says more than 10 000 people
have been killed in an estimated 13 000
drone strike in afghanistan
and so far no one has been held
accountable
the family's lawyer calls it a war crime
this was the last strike carried out by
u.s forces in afghanistan a reminder for
many afghans of the initial days where
madrasa's students were being killed in
drone strikes and for many here a legacy
of u.s presence for 20 years in this
country osama bin laden
kabul